[Music]
hello everyone and welcome to today's
webinar clarifying the development and
implementation of molecular tests in the
clinical laboratory my name is claru
from fisher scientific i'm a senior
region marketing market development
manager of asia pacific region in
genetic testing solutions team
today's educational web seminar is
presented by lab roots and brought to
you by thermo fisher scientific
i encourage you to participate by
submitting any questions that you may
have for our speakers during the
presentation to do so simply type your
question into the ask a question box and
click send
we will have a live q a session at the
end of the presentation where we will
try to answer as many of the questions
as time allows
any questions that we cannot get to will
be responded via the q a box or email
you may also submit any technical issues
in the chat box if you have trouble
seeing or hearing the presentation
now i would like to hand over the time
to one of our speaker mara espinon from
the health catalyst group who will
provide an introduction of the speakers
and our presentation mara over to you
thank you
thank you claire and it is wonderful to
be here and to be with all of you and we
have a very important topic this morning
but with a fun title this simple
sensible
salient and spellbinding seven questions
about laboratory develop tests and we
have fantastic speakers but first let me
share with you
the
disclaimer from thermo fisher scientific
our sponsor for today we're very
grateful for thermo fisher scientific
for making this event possible
so when we talk about our event today
it
we have four learning objectives
describing the different types of in
vitro diagnostic tests
the differences between in vitro
diagnostic tests often called ivds and
laboratory developed tests called ldt's
to list the benefits of running both the
ivd and ldt and explain how they are
designed and regulated in the u.s
there are many parallels between the u.s
and asia and other countries around the
world but we want to root our discussion
today to talk about how it's done in the
u.s
so to do that um we have um some great
speakers i'll start by just briefly
introducing myself as you heard mara
aspinall and i'm my career has been
based in the business of clinical
diagnostics i had the privilege of
serving as president of genzyme genetics
and ceo of roche tissue diagnostics
i have um worked on large companies and
small companies and right now
run a venture capital firm investing in
diagnostics
but probably the biggest privilege of my
life
is to be the co-founder of the school of
biomedical diagnostics at arizona state
university
and
with that we teach the business science
and technology of
the uh of diagnostics broadly both in
the u.s and around the world
but i'm only a small piece of this today
we have two fantastic speakers who are
the great leaders in the diagnostics
industry
first you will hear from dr marilyn
owens
marilyn is a senior healthcare executive
with over 40 years of extensive
management experience both establishing
and leading clinical reference
laboratories she has had that experience
in academic academic medical centers as
well as private and hospital labs
she has a broad scientific background in
immunology infectious disease oncology
genetics and molecular biology
and quite frankly much more
maryland has substantial lab operating
experience across the globe in asia in
europe and certainly in the us
she's always had p l responsibility with
both large and small labs and our
expertise spans
startups strategic planning and mergers
and acquisitions again for the labs and
the hospital systems that she's worked
with
marilyn is an experienced teacher mentor
and coach with graduate training in both
business and life sciences
our second speaker today
is dr
michael donovan and michael is also an
outstanding leader he has been a
registered patent attorney specializing
in patent prosecution and intellectual
property licensing and commercialization
for life science related technologies a
critical field
he has an academic background in
microbiology and a phd in immunology
after leaving private practice michael
worked as the intellectual property
council for the translational genomics
research institute and recently served
as the system director for intellectual
property at common spirit health
today
michael is a lecturer in the arizona
state university biomedical diagnostics
program where he teaches a variety of
areas including regulatory law health
economics and bioethics and michael was
just appointed the director of the
program
so we are thrilled to have these two
great speakers with us today and with
that i'm very pleased to hand it over to
you maryland
thank you maura i had to find the right
control
so uh the agenda today uh is really
following the very provocative title of
this seminar with the
the seven questions
and so we were going to try to answer
all seven of those questions in the
order of this agenda
the basics of diagnostic test
terminology so that we're all talking
about the same things
and then what is a laboratory developed
test
and how does it compare to an in vitro
diagnostic test
why use ldts
or why use ivds
who uses ldt's
and who uses ivds
when can i develop these tests
how do ldt's compare to ivds
and importantly how can a lab protect
their intellectual properties
in this slide we'll talk about test
terminology
in vivo which is in the body
there are lots of tests that are done in
vivo
physiology we have ekgs we have blood
pressures
in radiology there are x-rays ct and
other imaging
techniques mris and pet scans
but the technology in the in vivo test
is driven by physicians the physician is
there with the patient
doing the in vivo assessments
in the laboratory we're doing in vitro
which means we are doing them outside of
the body
in test tubes in
cultured plate plates in uh
microtiter plates a variety of different
uh holders but the testing is outside of
the body
the ivds are tests performed on body
fluids
that are
actually both the ivds and the ldt's are
performed on
body fluids taken from the body or cells
taken from the body or tissues taken
from the body
both ivds and ldt's
detect and quantify levels of desired
biomarkers which can be enzymes proteins
nucleic acids to diagnose
and
determine the body's function and
disorders the difference is in ivds
technology is driven by products
from
simple to complex
the simple chemistries to the complex
flow cytometries
in ldt's
technology is driven by the process that
you use to do the test
as we talk about the comparison between
ivds and ldt's
the differences are ivds are developed
by vendors for sale to diagnostic
laboratories health clinics or consumers
ldt's
can be developed by individual
laboratories but are not transferred
licensed or sold
with rare exception michael can answer
those questions
in ivds they're registered with the fda
their standardized instrument
qualification procedures and training is
required to perform the test exactly as
it's specified
the ldt's however
require of training and qualification
established by the individual laboratory
that has designed the ldt
the ivds use must be pre-validated with
data analysis and bioinformatics reports
that's done by the vendor
but the ldt's developed in-house are
developed mostly by necessity and
there's not a standard assay that was
available to compare to
ivd tests must be clinically validated
that's extremely important
ldt's must be clinically verified
and can be implemented quickly for
emergency use
they must be compliant with the
regulations of your laboratory of course
but they can be developed faster
there are a wide variety of assays for
different applications
and yet the molecular uh testing really
has a huge
number of opportunities
obviously respiratory pathogens like the
covid pandemic that we are still in
you can
have molecular tests for specific genes
and proteins linked to rare diseases
you can do genetic variants
you can have metabolites
pathogens
oncology markers
and now
even more you can have pharmacogenomic
markers which help to determine whether
or not an individual
can take a certain medication and have
it be effective within their bodies
there are a number of reasons for using
an ivd
in fact the main reason
is the vendor has done all the heavy
lift lifting
in order to use the test clinically
it needs to have been proven that it
works
and you have to have a supply of the
reagents and the equipment that you need
to do that test
that means that there's supply chain
that's taken on by the vendor
you have design controls that they have
done in their manufacturing process
it's easier to establish an ivd as a
gold standard because it's had fda or
other regulatory approval
it has to have adverse report event
reporting
in order to pass the regulatory
approvals
and of course in the process of
producing an ivd
it has to have manufacturing controls
and most importantly a complete clinical
validation
prior to marketing
that is the way that the clinical
validity
is uh enforced and
documented why would you do an i'd an
ldt if you could go uh to a vendor and
pull a kit off the shelf
well
there may not be a kit for what you want
to measure that's the main reason and
the the second reason would be
that you can't scale up an ivd test for
your desired throughput for example if
you wanted to go fully automated and the
test kits were only of a certain size
you may want to do a home brew
so that you could
expand the capability of your testing
using an ldt
an ldt could be an improvement over an
existing assay but because you've
changed what the ivd had it has to be
validated by you so therefore it becomes
an ldt
if an ldt
is developed in your laboratory it takes
less time that it does take a
manufacturer
to go through all of their manufacturing
controls all of their verification
testing as well as their clinical
utility validation
an ldt can help a laboratory remain
competitive that's another reason for
doing your own thing is to tailor make
your testing for your physician audience
advantages of ivds
certainly in quality systems
you have the built-in
requirements including the design
controls and manufacturing controls all
all the heavy lifting as i said has been
done by the vendors
inventory control is simple
uh you simply ask for an additional kit
or an additional vial of a certain
reagent you don't have to manufacture it
yourself
the technical support is there and you
can contact them to troubleshoot and
replace any products that didn't work as
you believe they should
the clinical validity is a big part of
ivds
the evaluation of the test ensures that
it detects or measured the specified
target or it's used in determining the
presence or absence of a clinical
condition
or predisposition so clinical validity
is a great advantage of an mvd
the broad distribution
of ivds means that it's out there in the
market and many laboratories would be
using it it means that you can compare
results
you can report proficiency
test results to confirm the accuracy of
the test by exchanges between
laboratories
now we look at the advantages of ldt's
uh the advantage the main advantage for
doing an ldt is that you control
what you're going to be measuring you
you can specifically
select relevant targets and applications
for your needs
you can rapidly adapt it
you can be
you can develop and then modify it
relatively quickly to respond to market
needs or changes in the clinical
situations
it's generally a lower cost per test
because you're not paying for the
overhead of the manufacturing processes
it's consolidation into a single test
and that's with multiple analytes i
think that we'll we'll talk a bit later
about
multiplexing and singleplexing for
especially molecular testing but that
allows you to get more data from a
single sample and may enable a faster
diagnosis as well
the laboratory qualification of the
quality management systems required by
all clinical laboratories cover the
qualifications for ldts
but it's not the case for the ivd kit
production
so i'm going to go through just this one
complex slide before michael talks
about the next area
and that's because the typical ldt
process from planning to launch is it's
a whole research project in its own
right
and i i believe that those of you who
have developed ldt's will agree with me
on this
that you you cannot do enough planning
to make sure that that you get through
all of these steps in there and
particularly in the the logical order to
save time
so first of all do you have a certified
lab are you
required to have a licensure in your
area and if so
are you ready to go
all right you have to plan for running
an ldt which would be
there's no other test you have what you
need to to do
the test in terms of equipment staffing
space
etc
is it a test or a panel
what targets will you have
how will you interpret the results
you have to do an analytical validation
to prove that the clinical testing works
and that means that you have to go
through specific areas of sensitivity
specificity
reproducibility accuracy and then the
interfering substances don't affect your
results
you have to have a clinical verification
which means you have to run some
clinical samples to be sure that you can
measure what you want to measure in
patients not just in contrived samples
however you don't have to do a clinical
utility study as the ivds need to do
when you launch the test this is your
marketing
you should have already been working
with your providers who would be
interested in this test and engage them
to be advocates for your laboratory and
the tests that you plan to offer
if possible you should publish
peer-reviewed papers utilizing your test
because that drives its own marketing
so now i'm going to turn over the
controls to michael
and he's going to start with regulation
thank you marilyn thank you for that
great introduction in terms of ivds and
ldt's um as marilyn just mentioned we
are now going to talk about regulation
um and one thing that i really want you
to to
remember as we talk about this
is ivds are more product driven um the
u.s food and drug administration or fda
regulates things you can think about it
in in terms of tangible goods ldts on
the other hand again are process driven
you can think of them as as akin to the
the practice of medicine as opposed to
these tangible goods that the fda
actually regulates so ibds are regulated
by the fda so long as they fall within
the fda's
mandate which is described here um
basically diagnostics include again
tangible items things like reagents
instruments and systems that are
intended for the use in the diagnosis of
disease or other conditions
the fda has this mandate and in terms of
regulating diagnostics
but this this mandate actually falls
under the larger heading of medical
devices so the fda regulates diagnostics
as medical devices so the class 1 class
2 and class 3
requirements and the associated
regulatory burdens associate
tied in with those classes play a big
role
so because we're regulating as medical
devices there are mainly two
two ways that that
a diagnostic can get to market through
the ivd pathway which is either
pre-market authorization
which is when you have something that's
basically a completely new diagnostic
without a predicate
that can take multiple years and quite
frankly millions of dollars to get
through in order to demonstrate uh
safety and efficacy of the test um and
those terms are generic because again uh
diagnostics are regulated as a device on
the other hand if there is a similar
device or a similar diagnostic out there
maybe you've come up with a new elisa or
a new rt pcr kit um that that can detect
based on a new biomarker um or maybe a
new snip that's been detected
you have the potential to go through the
510k pathway this is much more
abbreviated takes less time and costs
less
resources
in order to to reach the clearance stage
now with respect to
ivds that are not yet approved or
cleared by the fda there is an
opportunity for manufacturers
uh to generate some kind of revenue but
that is only
in the context of research use only or
investigational use only
[Music]
potential uses for that diagnostic
however
that is um
that does require proper labeling to
make sure that the consuming public uh
these clinical laboratories as well as
potentially research laboratories
refrain from using these types of
devices um uh in refrain from using them
as clinical diagnostic procedures and
then finally the fda has this
alternative pathway in the case of
public health emergencies the emergency
use authors authorization pathway this
provides expedited review and and
clearance of tests that are are designed
to
address that that public health need
obviously we saw this with the covet 19
pandemic but interestingly enough just
today we actually saw a few monkey pox
tests that cleared emergency use
authorization pathway at the fda i think
there's four or five
cleared clear tests at this point
now on the other hand ldt's remember an
ldt
is a as
is a diagnostic test but it is designed
manufactured and used within a single
clinical laboratory now the fda and this
is a point of contention the fda claims
that it could regulate
ldt's if it wants to but it is
exercising enforcement discretion and
basically punting the
the the regulation of these diagnostic
tests to other key stakeholders so under
the the 1988 clea amendments um which is
a
federal law here in the u.s um all
laboratories that test patient specimens
must obtain a certificate of compliance
or accreditation in order to build cms
and it is see a combination of cms as
well as
um
state regulators individual state
regulators
that do carry out a fair amount of the
regulation for ldt's
ldt's um and also uh
ivds as well tests in general are
categorized categorized into different
levels of complexity and we're actually
going to look at that on the next slide
and as i mentioned before there is uh
some controversies and disagreement in
terms of the fda's regulatory authority
but this was
even made more and uh challenging to
grasp back in 2020 when um the trump
administration
through the health and human services
department basically came out and said
fda does not have the authority to
regulate uh or to require emergency use
authorization for cova tests for for a
covet ldt test
well then a little bit more than a year
later in november 2021 um
with a new administration that new
administration came out and said no
fda does have that authority and fda
will in fact require eua's for uh cyrus
kovi ii um ldt's so it is it is an
ongoing uh
very murky area and interestingly enough
hopefully we'll get some clarity uh with
respect to the potential valid act
that's slowly making its way through the
the halls of congress
now as i mentioned there is this this
component of text test complexity um now
the fda
there's a lots of controversy in terms
of their role with ldt's but this is an
area where there is not controversy
the fda has the authority to make a
determination whether
a diagnostic test into which category
that diagnostic test falls
and that category then determines what
level of clia
clia certification is required for that
clinical laboratory and there are three
major categories there's wave tests
which are simple to form simple to
perform there's very low risk of
interpretation error and potentially
there is is relatively little clinical
significance
many of these tests are actually sold
over the counter such that consumers can
use them at home uh but at the same time
if they're running the lab there still
needs to be a
clear certificate for a clear waiver
certificate um as i said this these are
relatively simple tests pregnancy tests
strep tests glucometers um things that
that are are relatively challenging to
mess up
then there's moderate complexity tests
these are often performed with automated
equipment these are things like
electrolyte profiles chemistry profiles
cbc's urinalysis things that that
again are run on automation uh but there
is a an opportunity for for something to
go wrong and you want to ensure that
that your data is is reliable and
providing um good information to the
clinton clinician that reviews it and
then finally you have your high
complexity tests these often require
clinical laboratory expertise beyond
running automation and may require
additional data processing expertise as
well and these are your far more
complicated tests immunohistochemistry
flow cytometry
as well as most molecular diagnostics
like rtpcr
microwaves multiplexed analyses where
you have a much more challenging
technical environment
and you're going to have a much higher
uh regulatory burden when if you have
this high complexity
clia certificate
so
that was a very high level discussion of
regulatory issues but now i want to jump
into another legal issue and that is
intellectual property so there are kind
of you can view this as two sides to the
same coin there is first obtaining
intellectual property protection which
gives um the the owner of that
protection the ability to
um
to in to basically exclude others from
using the the the same types of
technology and on the other hand what
you'll see on the next slide there is
the the um
from an intellectual property
perspective there is the require there
is the need to ensure that you are
reducing your risk profile in terms of
potential infringement issues but first
from an ip protection standpoint there's
really two ways to view this here in the
united states um
it can be very challenging in some in
certain areas of um of diagnostics to
obtain ip protection especially if
you're using
conventional platforms with previously
known or previously published on
biomarkers so if for example someone is
has a a new rtpcr assay for
the latest covid uh variant but that
covet variant has been
published on or or the sequence has been
publicly released it's going to be very
challenging in order to to find uh to
obtain ip protection in those contexts
on the other hand there is the potential
for protection
if you are are
developing new platform technologies so
you come up with a new type of assay
there's
a hundred different ways you could
potentially protect that and gain market
advantage in those areas um also
improvements to conventional platform
technologies let's say
someone comes up with a
a new dyeing quencher for a qpcr
platform those are things that can be
protected there's also the potential to
protect biomarkers but here in the us
there is a a very important u.s supreme
court case
called mayo versus prometheus it's
actually mayo's clinical laboratory was
sued by prometheus
and the case went all the way to the
supreme court where the the the court
basically made it extremely challenging
to protect biomarkers in isolation you
would often need a fair amount of detail
in order to to
gain that that protection for those
biomarkers so um i i strongly suggest
that that if you are in a leadership
position in one of these clinical labs
to to engage early and often with ip
council in order to really grasp these
issues and one other option and i'll
just touch on this because this varies
greatly uh country by country is the
potential opposite for trade secret
protection of course
um that that is a a big issue for for
those who want to publish um but it is a
potential uh
uh a potential option for protection
so
as i mentioned before the flip side of
actually obtaining ip protection
uh is
minimizing your potential patent
infringement risk because patent
infringement regardless of whether or
not you get one patent or a hundred
patents on your your diagnostic via an
ivd or or an ldt patent infringement is
still a risk
as such as early as possible in the
development process of your essay again
this applies to both ibds and ldt's it
is a great idea to engage council to
conduct what's called a freedom to
operate search and potentially an fto
opinion so this is basically a daca
legal document that's prepared by
um
an attorney to basically provide
guidance to an organization in terms of
the the potential infringement issues
that are that are out there or if there
aren't any then that's great to know as
well um the results of an fta fto search
may necessitate the preparation of
either a patent invalidity or patent
non-infringement opinion again these are
are our potential avenues of of
mitigating risk even if you are sued
these are ways that you could
potentially reduce your damages
at least here in the united states um
this fto search can actually also work
in conjunction with obtaining patent
protection in terms of information you
might learn while conducting that search
and then the the search frankly might
also reveal some bad news in terms of
the need to in license
one or more patents
um and obviously this is jurisdiction by
jurisdiction specific uh we're just
talking about the u.s here but those are
just some of the the key
legal issues that that crop up
with different diagnostic assays now
with that i'm going to turn it over back
to mara so she can talk a little bit
about some copic 19 specific discussions
thank you michael and thank you for that
excellent summary and following
um maryland's and i'm going to take it
from there to talk just a little bit
about covet 19.
many of us have heard enough about covet
19
but i'm just going to give you a few
statistics around that and then we'll
move on to the q a
michael talked about this and the
importance of ldt's and particular as
part of the covet 19 pandemic response
and the emergence of something called an
eua and in many countries around the
world that had this same type of process
and authorization as opposed to approval
i think what was very impressive
with covid19 from a testing point of
view is that it only took 10 days
for the first um genome sequencing to be
done on sars cov2 and just to give you a
context that compares to having it take
taken a month for the last sars pandemic
so our epidemic didn't quite get to the
extent that we have to do with what we
have on covet 19 today
so when we look at that you're probably
familiar with it but we look at two
kinds of tests the tests that are
looking at the virus and looking for the
virus elements
in the genome or the proteins of the
virus itself and then we're also looking
at the immune reaction either with b
cells t cells or antibodies we can also
look at that immune reaction through
systemic
biometric dynamics but not really the
focus of what we are today
but i think as we look at that i wanted
to give what i'll call the history and
the the past present and future of covid
testing in one slide
so when i talk about this i think it'll
give hopefully you a very good overview
of where we are and where we're going in
covid testing
so it starts with the fact that at the
very beginning it was all about syst
sorry
it was all about symptomatic diagnostics
lung cts and bronchial average it moved
from there to active disease diagnosis
pcr and
viral antigens we move from there to
screening testing which is done
worldwide now individual or pooled pcr
and we know very much the rapid antigen
tests
but what i think is where we're going
today and in some countries we're
already there it's all going to be about
surveillance testing
and what that is is air quality
monitoring breath tests covert sniffing
dogs scratch and snaf and waste water
are they as precise as pcr they're not
but they can play a very important role
from a public health perspective
the second way to think about these
tests are where they're being done they
started in hospitals moved to the
central lab moved from there to point of
care and now um virtually worldwide
they're all in home or self-tests
but as we do that where are they being
invasive it started in the lungs moving
to what we call semi-invasive the
nasopharyngeal swabs that go all the way
to the back of the nose
then minimally invasive
with the short anterior nasal
and then to passive and non-invasive but
any time we look at an industry it's
important to follow the money
and you all know that lab tests have
gone from a thousand plus dollars doing
it in us dollars to a few hundred to
tens of dollars and i believe before the
end of this year
that tests will be broadly available
less than five dollars we're just
beginning to see these rapid antigen
tests in the u.s go below five dollars
so what are these tests and where have
they been and how do the numbers stack
up well through a grant from the
rockefeller foundation as part of
something called testingcommons.com
you can look at what we believe are the
vast majority of tests available not
just in the us but around the world
but when you look at this chart you'll
see over 400 fda ewas
ldt's as michael described had started
at the beginning of the pandemic we then
have the eu self-certification
of ce ivds well more than a thousand
ruo tests in the us not for clinical use
tests and development that are not being
used anywhere but the new technologies
and i'll describe a little bit about
those
and then what's very interesting in the
u.s but also true around the world the
tests that got
approvals that got authorizations but
then were revoked so it's very important
to emphasize that for our customers so
if we look at that let me just share
a few other charts to say in the u.s the
vast majority of tests that were
authorized were molecular tests and
within the molecular test 86 percent of
them were pcr
antibody were number two and antigen a
relatively small number of tests but now
being used very broadly if you look at
this in many countries around the world
you will see this antibody
number be much higher
but as i mentioned the fda has about 85
antibody tests on the market today but
they were more than double that 170 of
those tests that had their euas revoked
how does that compare to tests in
development
those tests in development
molecular is still number one but now
antigen is number two and this is the
pandemic to date and what's interesting
here if you look at this molecular area
you remember i said before it was 86
percent pcr
now we see much more diversity only 38
percent pcr 23 percent other molecular
with isothermal and 14
crisper and 13 sequencing obviously very
much related so we have um a lot more
diversity of the test and development
worldwide i suspect that you'll see many
of these tests come to market but they
will not just be coveted it will be
covered flu a b and c a a and b
as well as rsv
lastly the question we're asked a lot
and i'm sure you're very familiar with
it is the sars cov2 variants i ask five
questions when we look at these variants
does it make the test less accurate and
to date the answer is no and as a
laboratory industry we need to continue
to publish and have the data available
that our tests are working whether in
the lab molecular
other tasks that the tests are still
accurate with different variants clearly
we have to check that but important does
it increase cases and deaths we know
that does it make some treatments
ineffective it does
vaccine effectiveness is a tricky area
we won't go into detail on that or raise
the hurdle on herd immunity but we know
that variants are really what it's about
so to summarize and to end
i'd like to pers provide a little bit of
perspective on the sars cov2 epidemic
and what you see here is a chart that
looks a case fatality rate versus are
not or transmissibility or
infectiousness
and as we look at that you can see that
there are diseases going back
for a very long time as we looked at the
plague that had a tremendous case
fatality rate
rabies at 100 percent of untreated but
in
many of these you see tb
and other infectious diseases that were
highly fatal however they were not
easily spread the dangerous ones are the
ones
that are both highly infectious
and highly transmissible happily there's
nothing in that box but what you see is
if you move from covid wuhan
to delta to omicron you see it's
becoming less deadly partly because of
hurt immunity but it's also becoming
more and more contagious so i wanted to
give that historical perspective and
hopefully we will see covid continue to
go down in this chart
so to summarize the great work that um
marilyn and michael talked about today
ldt's and ivds are central to patient
care their ldt's are important locus of
diagnostic innovation
they leverage a regulatory system that
has the ability to quickly adapt and
they're tied to laboratory processes
where ivds are tied to laboratory tests
so with that i'd like to
ask marilyn and
michael to come back on screen
and we're going to take questions from
the audience
welcome back it is great to see you
and i'm going to start with our first
question we have about 15 minutes
and the first question um
is is a new one to us which is i think
this marilyn goes to you
what if there are no other labs running
a similar task to the ldt the novel test
for comparison or concordance how does a
lab perform the clinical validation
procedures
that that's an excellent question
because if you're the first to do it
then you have to do
more of an analytical
validation proof
with a
test group of clinical patients
that means you work very closely with
your physician groups
and the tests that you have designed for
a patient population you really need to
have the kind of before during and after
picture of the patients you're testing
so it's a lot more documentation
it's still possible
but what you need to do obviously is to
impress the physicians to using the test
that it is worth using
and using it on their patients is
generally the best way to do that
thank you marilyn our next um and
as you said very important question our
next question i think michael goes to
you
um we talked a lot about the various
different types of clinical diagnostics
where do ruo assays fit in can they be
used as clinical diagnostics or not
well they they can but they they aren't
used uh under their ivd heading um so i
mean it again depending on on the
the the laboratory and the laboratories
um clia certificate
um some of those rus can actually be
deployed as ldt's um and in fact some uh
analyte specific reagent manufacturers
asr manufacturers um will sell
uh ruo type
kits
to be used in in that ldt process or in
that yeah in the ldt process for for
more clinical diagnostics
and i should clarify ruo though is
research use only
so they have to be reported differently
than a classic clinical diagnostic
well no it would still be part of a uh
nldt um i mean all the steps that
maryland discussed in terms of launching
an ldt would still have to be undertaken
um it's not one of those those kind of
ready-to-wear type assays like you would
run into with a with a with an ibd
um so you would still have to go through
to perform your your validation uh steps
but it is something that that could be
done um in a lab that is properly
certified
super thank you
uh marilyn next one to you
um you've had so much experience how
long generally does it take for your lab
a lab to develop a molecular diagnostic
before
making it
be you know go live and available for
patients
well how long is the
function of a lot of things
the type of test if it's a pcr test
obviously that would take a different
amount of time than if you were trying
to do an elisa
and if you had a patient population that
you were really targeting
can you get sample patients because
that's going to be your limiting factor
so i would say that in general
if you have a dedicated team or tech or
department
to develop ldt's
you're probably looking at two to three
months to develop
if you're doing it part-time
with available talent
it may take you six months
and related to that marilyn so thank you
is there a minimum number of samples
required for the clinical validation as
part of the assay development
uh there are lots of guidelines that
give recommendations for the numbers of
samples i think the
clsi is probably the best
resource because they have a number of
publications of various technologies for
example nucleic acid testing elisa
testing clinical chemistry testing
and they will give you guidelines for
how many samples you need to use for
both analytical validations as well as
clinical
if you go to the
quick and dirty
leased
number
in the u.s that new york state will
is one of the agencies that actually
will review ldt's and will grant the
approval for them to be used on new york
state patients
they use a number of around 30. as the
number that they would like to see in
the ldt's now obviously multiplexing
makes it a little more challenging
because you have to be able to
ensure that you don't have cross
reactivity
or interference but uh between 20 and 30
positive cases and then of course an
equal number of negative ones would be
the minimum
thank you and that was consistent with
the euas for covid where i believe it
was 30 positive and negative cases
um michael i think this is to you um
could ldt validated data become ivd data
for an fda application
um i mean it depends on
whether or not it is it is that data
itself would
be considered
clinical trial worthy data i mean if it
is i mean obviously if the ldt has been
been validated that's that's great
that's a that's a big benefit but that
is something that could
um lend credence and conversely there
are actually obligations to submit
um
uh kind of all information to the fda so
if your ldt is not working out real well
um you you might actually also and
you're and that's what you want to push
forward for an ibd um that's something
that that could also kind of kind of
backfire as well
um that being said i mean you also have
to remember
who's running an ldt and whose menu
who would be a sponsor for an ibd
application
i mean a sponsor for an ibd application
is going to be a manufacturer
and a clinical laboratory is going to be
the one that's that's that's um
developing validating and deploying an
ldt there are there's not often going to
be a lot of overlap there it's the
clinical laboratory has a very different
focus
uh than than ivd manufacturer as well
super thank you for that and giving the
additional context there
marilyn this harkens back to some of
what you talked about if somebody has
validated a custom panel
what should they do when they're
deciding to add more targets or more
pathogens to that existing panel how
difficult a process is that
it depends on whether it's a panel of
individual
pcrs
or whether you have a multiplexed panel
because in either case you're going to
have to revalidate but the extent extent
that you have to revalidate is different
for those
because if you are
mixing reagents you have to prove that
you haven't interfered with anything by
adding a new one but if you've simply
added a new pcr marker separately all
you have to do is run a few clinical
samples and prove that it may that it
works that it makes sense
and then related to that i think we know
the answer but does an ldt need to
compare with an existing method for
validation
if if there is one yes uh and if there
isn't as i said you have to kind of do
your own clinical uh validation
right so i think the easiest way is to
make sure that you have uh
physicians with patients lined up
so that if need be you can go directly
into the patient samples
that's actually a great point
about those patient samples and
physicians
lined up michael from a legal point of
view what are the concerns and issues
that a lab needs to think about as
they're going through that process
permissions and and otherwise
yeah no i mean i think permission is
going to be
a huge issue um i mean especially if the
the clinical laboratory ever wants to
publish any of this data which can
from a u.s perspective can can kind of
feed into a reimbursement question
um
i mean i think permission is is what's
going to be key at that point
is that sample
um
is the laboratory ever going to do
anything with that sample um that that
would want to follow the wishes of the
the person from which it originated
um and obviously there's also issues
tied into um
uh can the laboratory retain part of
that sample
um because i mean that's one of the ways
that that you can
um
uh
check can laboratory and um
competency to continue doing competency
testing is by testing
samples that are no negatives and
positives
and those if those are clinical samples
you need that level of permission in
order to kind of hold on to that sample
as well
that's actually a great point michael
that you bring up um
proficiency testing are there any
guidelines that labs can refer to
if they're not in a network that has an
automatic system for proficiency testing
is that you marilyn
well i'd say
contact cap first since they do have a
proficiency testing program
and if they don't have their own
guidelines which i believe they do have
they could certainly point you in the
direction of what guidelines they follow
super and cap is the college of american
pathology
um but despite the having american in
the name it's
operates worldwide and is something that
many many labs outside of the u.s have
cap it's often called cap certification
so thank you for that um let me ask that
another question skipping a little bit
around not necessarily a molecular
diagnostic but we had questions about
flow cytometry
and other sort of clinical chemistry
tests how do ldt tests overlap with
something like flow cytometry
uh that's a rough one because flow
cytometry is more a technology
right if you're going to add reagents to
that technology then you have to be
absolutely certain your reagents are
appropriate so it's hard to say it would
be an ldt
because many of those are either
monoclonal antibodies or specific
protein binding
uh that it's unlikely an ldt would
create uh michael what do you think
about that
no i mean i i agree it's i mean if
i think oftentimes your flow cytometry
reagents if it is going to be a
diagnostic essay it's probably going to
be more on the ibd side of things
um just
by the the nature of what is being
supplied that's like um almost saying
uh
asking about a pcr machine so i mean
your your your pcr machine itself might
might be uh cleared as a medical device
depending on on kind of what it's you
being used for but then on top of that
you you've got the actual reagents that
are being used
supers to those asrs well we just have
time for two quick additional questions
one's not easy but um what is the
difference maryland between a clea and a
cap certification because people hear
that all the time clia and cap oh
okay uh well clear is actually the us
government's uh authorization of a
clinical laboratory license
whereas cap is an elective one where you
apply to the college to also be
inspected and certified by them
but you have to have clia first
thank you for that marilyn and they're
both kind of difficult to to get through
so you have to be prepared
and speaking of prepared last question
then i'll hand it back over to claire
but
a question about i don't have enough
manpower for lab doesn't have enough
manpower for validation can thermo
fisher cover validation so i'm gonna i'm
gonna hand that over to you claire to
both answer and then wrap us up but i'm
going to say thank you for all the great
questions and our terrific presentations
from dr owens and dr donovan
it's been a pleasure to join you and to
be with you today
thank you very much mara marilyn and
michael for your time today and your
informative presentation and let me
answer the last quick question first so
yes thermal fissure can uh provide and
we do provide the analytical validation
services um and um in terms of the
clinical validation services we can help
you to engage with some of the the local
vendors that can support you further on
that so for any more details you can
always reach out to your
corresponding sales rep for more
information about those
so with that i know uh we're at time but
before we go i would like to thank all
the audience for joining us today and
for their interest question interesting
questions and questions um we do not
have time for today and those submitted
doing the on demand period we will
definitely uh address those by this uh
definitely by the speakers and via the
contact information that you provided
um at the time that you did the
registration
and so lastly i would like to remind you
all that there are a few resources
available for you to download and what's
being covered by our speakers today
could also be found in those education
papers and there's also more detailed
information that you can find there
and this webcast can be viewed on demand
lab routes will also alert you via email
when it's available for a replay and we
definitely encourage you to share the
email with your colleagues who have
missed today's events
so until next time uh goodbye to you all
and thank you again for all our speakers
bye
you